let's face it is looking more and more
like Trump offered a quid pro quo to
Ukraine in exchange for dirt on Joe
Biden that's really how it's starting to
look what's gonna happen from that we
don't know but despite all that despite
all of that many people don't know much
about Ukraine's history or they don't
know much about its relationship with
the Trump administration that's why as a
public service to our viewers I asked
Andy to dive into the story and fill in
the blanks Andy thanks Conan here's what
I found out what I found out is that I
don't like to be told what to do with
the last minute I only came into my
office at 1:30 this afternoon saying
Andy we're under in the show by two
minutes could you whip up a funny thing
about the Ukraine scandal what the hell
do I know about the Ukraine scandal when
I get mad i stressing so here I am the
photos on my third Cuban sandwich so on
top of being pissed at Conan I'm gonna
be mad at myself because these
sandwiches are gonna sit in my gut all
day and let me tie my burp it's a
reminder that I blew my diet my hair
doesn't say that I have to acknowledge
my part in this which is saying yes to
it rather than saying no I mean what I
should have said was Conan I can't write
shoot and edit a good piece about the
Ukraine scandal not in the time that
you've given me I mean not if you want
me to do a good job
I would just like for there to be one
day around here that doesn't go off the
rail here why me now but still I mean I
did say yes and I want to keep my word
so here's my report on the Ukraine
crisis how much time do I have left at
four seconds four seconds oh well then
back to your Conan
I I did the best like yeah I know I know
good job